what do you think how many alien
civilizations are out there ask Robin
Hansen he has this lovely grabby aliens
paper which is the uh more or less the
only argument I've ever seen for where
are they how many of them are there
based on
a very clever argument that if you have
a bunch of locks of different difficulty
and you are randomly trying a keys to
them the solutions will be about evenly
spaced even if the locks are of
different difficulties
in the rare cases where a solution to
all the locks exist in time when Robin
Hansen looks at like the arguable hard
steps in human civilization coming into
existence
and how much longer it has left come
into existence before for example all
the waters looks back under the uh the
the under the crust into the mantle and
so on
and infers that the aliens are about
half a billion to a billion light years
away and it's like quite a clever
calculation it may be entirely wrong but
it's the only time I've ever seen
anybody like even come up with a halfway
good argument for how many of them where
are they
do you think
their development of Technologies do you
think that their Natural Evolution
whatever however they grow uh and
develop intelligence do you think it
ends up at AGI as well
something if it ends up anywhere it ends
up at AGI
like maybe there are aliens who are just
like the Dolphins
and it's just like too hard for them to
forge metal and you know this is not
you know maybe if you if you have aliens
with no technology like that they keep
on getting smarter and smarter and
smarter and eventually the Dolphins
figure like the super Dolphins figure
out something very clever to do given
their situation and they still
end up with high technology and in that
case they can probably solve their AGI
alignment problem if they're like much
smarter before they actually confronted
because they saw had to like solve a
much harder environmental problem to
build computers their their chances are
probably like much better than ours
I I do worry that like most of the
aliens who are like humans are are you
know like like a modern human
civilization I kind of worry that the
super vast majority of them are dead
given given how far we seem to be from
solving this problem
foreign but some of them would be more
Cooperative than us so that would be
smarter than us hopefully some of the
ones who are smarter than and more more
Cooperative than us that are also nice
and hopefully there are some
galaxies out there full of things that
say I am I wonder
but I it doesn't seem like we're on
course to have this galaxy be that
does that in part give you some hope in
response to the threat of AGI that we
might reach out there towards the stars
and find
no if they if if the nice aliens were
already here they would like have
stopped the Holocaust you know that's
like that's a valid argument against the
existence of God it's also a valid
argument against the existence of nice
aliens and un nice aliens would have
just eaten the planet so no aliens
you've uh had debates with Robin Hansen
that you mentioned uh so one particular
I just want to mention is the idea of AI
foom or the ability of AGI to improve
themselves very quickly uh what's the
case you made and what was the case he
made
the thing I would say is that among the
thing that humans can do humans can do
is design new AI systems and if you have
something that is generally smarter than
a human it's probably also generally
smarter at building AI systems this is
the ancient argument for foom put forth
by IJ good and probably some science
fiction writers before that
um but I don't know who they would be
well what's the argument against film
various people have various different
arguments none of which I think hold up
you know like there's only one way to be
right in many ways to be wrong
um
a argument that some people have put
forth is like well what if intelligence
gets like exponentially harder to
produce as a thing needs to become
smarter and to this the answer is well
look at Natural Selection spitting out
humans we know that it does not take
like exponentially more resource
Investments to produce like linear
increases in competence in hominids
because
each mutation
that rises to fixation like if the
impact it has in small enough it will
probably never reach fixation
so and there's like only so many new
mutations you can fix per generation so
like given how long it took to evolve
humans we can actually say with some
confidence that there were not like
logarithmically diminishing returns on
the individual mutations increasing
intelligence
so
example of like
fraction of sub debate and the thing
that Robin Hansen said was more
complicated than that than like a brief
summary he was like well you'll have
like we won't have like one system
that's better at everything you'll have
like a bunch of different systems that
are good good at different narrow things
and I think that was falsified by gpt4
but probably Robin Hansen would say
something else